Plateau and two of his texts the lashes
and the symposium explains how Socrates
recalls an episode from the famous
battle of ilium in 424 BC between the
Athenians and the bo Asians the synopsis
fish passage goes as follows
consider a soldier at the front of the
bow Asian line having the following
realization before defense successful I
still risk the chance of dying if our
defense is unsuccessful
I will almost certainly die based on
this reasoning it seems that the best
alternative for the soldier is to run
away regardless of who is going to win
the battle now imagine if all soldiers
were to exhibit this very reasoning at
the same time if such an event would
occur they would all probably realize
that they would be better off running
away the seemingly simple yet incredibly
reasonable hypothesis it's one of the
first historical instances of game
theory flash-forward two thousand three
hundred and sixty eight years in 1944
Hungarian American mathematician John
von Neumann published a book titled fear
of games and economic behavior this
foundational work contains the method
for finding mutually consistent
solutions for two-person zero-sum games
this great book introduced game theory
as a concept thus extending its
application to Phil's like economics
politics and sports and leading to the
expansion of the array of scientists
that showed interest in it one of those
scientists was the legendary John Nash
who won the Nobel Memorial Prize in
Economic Sciences in 1994 and
popularized a day of game theory as we
know it today something very fundamental
about game theory is that it doesn't get
its name from the preconceived notion of
game as we understand it
a game in game theory is an interaction
between multiple people in which its
players payoff is affected by the
decisions of others namely any single
interaction of you're part of can be
analyzed with game theory in order to
produce the most beneficial outcome but
before we get into the mechanics let's
lay out the main principles number one a
game needs to include multiple players
number two the players need to interact
with each other number three there needs
to be a reward
number four we assume that players act
rationally number five we assume that
players act according to their personal
self-interest prisoner's dilemma is the
most widely mentioned game in game
theory the basic premise is how to
establish a mutually beneficial strategy
between two members of a gang that got
arrested and faced potentially
imprisonment the rules are as follows
number one the players of the game are
prisoner a and prisoner B number two the
players can communicate with each other
number three if a and B each betray each
other each of them serves two years in
prison number four if a betrays B but B
remains silent a will be set free and B
will serve three years in prison and
vice versa and number five if a and B
both remain silent both of them will
only serve one year in prison this
matrix depicts the different choices of
each member and signifies the number of
years to serve according to each
prisoner's dilemma exemplifies to a
great degree the substrate of human
nature the rational self-interest driven
gang member will most probably choose to
betray his counterpart thinking that he
will get a better deal this
idiosyncratic choice will most certainly
lead to a disaster for both parties
since they will get the worst deal
possible the obvious mutually beneficial
choice here is to keep silent
the main idea behind this game is to
expose the inherent tendency of humans
to display lack of cooperation in decent
similar games game theorists usually
coined the terms dominant strategy and
Nash equilibrium to distinguish the kind
of strategies followed by the players
those two terms are usually used
together and form the basis upon which
game theory is founded dominant strategy
refers to strategies that are better
than other strategies for one player no
matter how the opponent may play those
strategies might be creating the case of
non alternatives but if you're part of a
game with more dominant strategies which
means its player has his own dominance
urging then they aren't optimal in the
prisoner's dilemma case the dominant
strategy for each player is to betray
and here is where the term Nash
equilibrium comes into play the term is
used since John Nash explained the
essentiality of equilibrium in his
landmark work equilibrium points in end
person games in essence what he proposed
is that even high-level competitive
games like Google versus Apple or USA
versus Russia there exists an
equilibrium where no side would benefit
by changing its course at this
equilibrium each side knows its
adversary very well and sticks to its
strategy for instance in the prisoner's
dilemma the Nash equilibrium is the
upper-left square of the matrix which
means both prisoners need to stay silent
what makes nasa's theory of equilibrium
so special is that it presupposes that
in each game there is at least one point
of equilibrium and all players will be
better off trying to find it and form
their strategy around it this momentous
revelation help people in disciplines
like politics war economics business and
social theory understand the world
better and form better strategies the
inception of Nash equilibrium was
portrayed exceptionally in the wonderful
movie
beautiful mind press
yes stop shuffling your papers for five
sighs not by you gentlemen here anyone
else feel she should be moving in slow
motion will she want a large wedding you
think so we say swords gentlemen pistols
at dawn have you remembered nothing they
call the lessons of Adam Smith the
father of modern economics in
competition individual ambition serves
the common go exactly every man for
himself gentlemen and those who strike
out or stop with their friends I'm not
gonna strike out you can lead a blonde
the water but you can't make a drink I
don't think he said all right nobody
move all right he may have the upper
hand now we wait until you
[Music]
Adam Smith needs revision what are you
talking about
we all go for the blonde
[Music]
we block each other not a single one of
us it's going to get her so then we go
for her friends but they will all give
us the cold shoulder because nobody
likes to be second choice but if no one
goes for the blonde
we don't get in each other's way and we
don't install the other girls see me we
win that's the only way we all get laid
even if people or companies rationally
follow their own self-interest the best
outcome is hard to reach when they can't
or don't cooperate therefore the best
strategy is to continually scan the
market for potential alliances people
who can forge strong alliances will
eventually become part of we go police
and thus dominate their market the rest
will consequently be ostracized that's
what I love about game theory it
approaches the game of life from its
most axiomatic principle that of
evolution evolution equals adaptation
and therefore life is an omnipresent
game of adaptation humans thrive in
cooperation because it is the main
strategy that helped us survive and
thrive after years of adversity and
struggle to compete against different
forces of nature the sad thing is that
after establishing our sovereignty we
overpowered other species and in most
occasions nature itself but eventually
we turned ourselves against each other
there are a variety of factors that
affect the descent to the point we have
reached but a game theory mindset can
work to our advantage I always believed
that change in equilibrium start at the
micro level and that is something we
fail to grasp because we are usually
consumed by events at the macro it is
interesting to be in the know and
discuss and argue about politics and
national strategies but at the end of
the day the trigger is pulled by the
respective strategists what each of us
could do instead is to use game theory
in our most challenging decisions in
their closest relationships
regardless of what decision you have
made and how this will impact your
future think like a game theorist upon
their questions like are the actors in
the situation rational are we able to
reach Nash equilibrium do they act
according to their self-interest do they
understand the rules of the game is
their dominant strategy really that
dominant if you see that most game
theory parameters aren't met you know
that you have to change your approach
you either need to also act irrationally
which is something I wouldn't suggest or
you need to step away and find better
players or games the choice is always
yours life often times feels like a game
and usually the winners are those who
know how to play hi everyone today's a
great day it is a great day because this
is my first attempt to head towards a
new trajectory in my creative endeavors
most of you probably know me from my
blog the quintessential mind where I
have been focusing on creating essays on
personal development psychology
philosophy culture and sometimes even
business from now on I will also try to
immerse myself in the art of video
making by transforming some of my essays
into video essays and thus adding a more
visual aspect to my words and ideas I
started with game theory because it is a
topic that always fascinated me it is
quite a complex topic but even by
understanding its fundamental principles
one can experience tremendous benefits
in the way one makes decisions I hope
you enjoyed this video as much as I
enjoyed creating it and that it worked
as a great primer to warm you up for
what is about follow if this is the case
please make sure to like it share it
with people that you think will benefit
from it and also subscribe and hit the
notification button so you can be
notified when I will release my next
video which will actually happen pretty
soon thanks again for watching
take care